à Montréal le froid polaire a donné bien
du fil à retordre aux pompiers qui ont
dû combattre un incendie majeur dans
l'est de la ville s'il n'y a pas eu de
blessés une vingtaine de familles
devront trouver à se reloger au cours
des prochains jours
je me disais avec le froid
ça doit vraiment pas être évident à
éteindre un feu la nuit a aussi été
occupé dans les refuges qui sont
confrontés à une forte demande
capacité maximale d'accueil normalement
on a 55 places puis nos équipes
évidemment décident de ne pas refuser
personne donc on est monté jusqu'à 80
personnes à certains moments des
policiers patrouillent d'ailleurs la
nuit pour rejoindre les personnes sans
abri on va les vérifier on va aller
s'assurer de leur bien-être si on peut
les relocaliser dans une salle de
chaleur dans les rues le pas est rapide
et les humeurs variables elle est très
froide mais nous on s'en va en appétit
c'est sûr mais on apprend à vivre avec
on savait plus chaud température ce
matin est insupportable et malgré le
soleil prévu ce week-end le froid
extrême rend les conditions d'épandage
sur les routes plus difficiles avec des
risques de dérapage
accruste de visibilité on prend une
visibilité qui est jusqu'à nul c'est une
forte poudrerie donc ils ont va être
vraiment sur leur garde en fin de
semaine
malgré le beau temps le soleil ça
signifie pas que les routes la surface
de route n'est pas dénuée de glace des
patrouilleurs de la Sûreté du Québec et
du ministère des transports seront
déployés aux abords des ponts pour
ralentir le trafic les garagistes qui
vont de leur recommandation en prévision
d'un week-end à chalandais premièrement
ne pas partir avec un auto qui est
froide laissez réchauffer le tout le
plus possible peu après ça ne pas aller
à des vitesses trop rapides le froid
joue aussi les troubles fêtes à Ottawa
Gatineau les activités du bal des neiges
sont repoussés tout comme celles du
Carnaval de Québec et plusieurs stations
de ski ont décidé de rester fermés au
moins jusqu'à samedi après-midi
tout pour encourager les gens à rester
au chaud mais les grands froids et les
vents forts provoquent déjà des milliers
de pannes d'électricité ici Camille Faye
zen Radio-Canada Montréal